feels like if we were talking about
doing this 10 or 15 years ago that would
be a really arduous process to actually
get the business started get it launched
and start testing whether it works or
not today with the no code kind of
movement a lot of the businesses that
are getting created there that's much
easier and I know you've talked a little
bit about the no code stuff before but
maybe kind of just give us an your
perspective on kind of where we are
today and how you see that specific
vertical developing over the next couple
of years yeah so I mean my I said
earlier I was I'm super high pace I love
seeing stuff happen quickly and so I
used to get really frustrated I'm
originally a designer I would design
something in Photoshop and I'd hand it
off to a front-end developer to do it in
HTML or start building a web app or
whatever and I get so frustrated because
it would always take a day or two to do
it and I didn't know enough I didn't
know JavaScript I couldn't get in there
and tweak it and stuff and so when I
started using web flow about four or
five years ago I was like holy crap this
is amazing I don't have to worry about
hosting or coding I can just myself
design something and build it and so I
ended up building the original tiny
Capitol website and it was such an
awesome experience because I had the
idea and executed it within 24 hours and
so you know no code since then is
obviously growing a lot that web flow is
just for websites but this idea that
with very very simple tools you can
basically clone something like Airbnb or
you could build a you know a complex
form or something like that where you're
piecing together all these different
services and basically making a web app
without coding I think is very powerful
because you can test an idea you can
come up with an idea for an MVP and you
can see if you can get revenue and
validate the idea before you go out and
raise money and hire a whole bunch of
people and go through that and so it
shortens the cycle to get to product
market fit and to get to a point where
you have a basic MVP and I don't think
that you know we're not going to be
running Airbnb should not be running on
no code platforms right like it's not
about that it's about okay
the really simple version of it it's
like if you look at Axios Axios has all
these newsletters they could have and
they probably do use MailChimp or Aweber
or something like that to start but then
as they get bigger yeah maybe they build
their own custom code but it enables
people to get started and move quickly
and so you know you see that same effect
the Squarespace effect of your
restaurant you don't need a web
developer I think the same thing is
gonna happen with Web Apps and pretty
soon mobile apps and I'm super excited
about that from just the idea of testing
MVPs what I'm really interested in is
the idea of you know right now it's not
worth anyone owning a business that
requires developers and coding that does
say a hundred or two hundred thousand
dollars a year simply because there's no
way to employ the people you need and
still make a profit with no code I think
there's a potential to have a two
hundred thousand dollar a year business
that is actually profitable and makes
someone a hundred thousand and well I'm
not interested in that scale I think
it's gonna empower a lot of people to
have the freedom to run their own
businesses and have a nice life and then
use that capital to do more interesting
things instead of being a developer at
Facebook or something yeah I think part
of what at least fascinates me from what
I understand about the businesses you
guys own there's a lot of venture
capitalists and private equity folks who
would look and say you know what is the
moat the I only invest in infrastructure
businesses and they kind of have this
cookie cutter approach to to what they
will invest in or buy with you you
actually appear to be willing to go kind
of the full stack so everything from
marketplaces like the dribbles of the
world except sure all the way to a
furniture business which is really just
an e-commerce store right and you're
selling any widget through that but it
happens to be a really nicely done piece
of furniture and so it feels to me like
the no code movement really empowers
some of the things that are actually
outside of the sweet spot of most
venture capital and private equity folks
you mentioned it based on scale but also
it almost seems like the types of
businesses as well right I don't know
how many of them are going out looking
for
kind of I want to invest in a furniture
manufacturer right that sells online
maybe at some you know huge scale that
you know and kind of blitzscale it if
you will but what you guys are really
building there it seems like that would
be outside their wheelhouse something
like no code and powers that to be done
quickly though is that fair to say yeah
I mean I think no code empowers both
venture businesses and normal but you
know just run-of-the-mill sustainability
simple $200,000 your lifestyle
businesses what is interesting is
there's a company we invested in called
flytographer which is a global network
of travel photographers so the idea is
let's say you're in Italy in Venice and
you want to you know remember that truck
forever and so you schedule a Travel
Photographer to show up in a square at a
certain time and take photos of you and
your family and it's super pro so
instead of having crappy photos by dad
you got this beautiful photo album and
it was really interesting the founder
she originally for the first two years
of the business just had a Squarespace
website a very well designed Squarespace
website you wouldn't know if you looked
at it and it was a forum and so you
basically would click through and then
there'd be a series of questions of
where are you and you know you want a
book and what city are you in and all
this kind of stuff and she actually got
to hundreds of thousands or maybe even
millions of dollars of revenue off of
the Squarespace site before then going
out raising money and hiring a bunch of
people and what it enabled her to do was
validate the idea but also she could
delay raising money and by delaying
raising money she increased her
potential evaluation for her first raise
so she owns way more of the business
than she would have if she'd gone out
raised an angel round and a seed round
before getting revenue so I think stuff
like that is super interesting and
that's a very old-school version of that
that's just a Squarespace site think
about like somebody who does like a
marketplace or you know Airbnb style
website it could get pretty far on no
code